70 years ago, nuclear bombs exploded in Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
Therefore, it has become the only nuclear weapon used to actual combat.
But there are 15,000 nuclear warheads in the world.
What happens if a nuclear war occurs? The influence of a nuclear bomb is determined by many factors, such as: weather, weapon design.
The geographical environment in which the nuclear bomb hits, and the nuclear bomb is in the air, on the surface or underground.
About 35% of the energy comes from heat radiation or heat
Thermal radiation will advance at the speed of matt
Within a few seconds before the explosion, light and heat will appear, and anyone who watches the explosion at this time
There will be flash blindness (flash Blindness), a temporary blindness of up to a few minutes. A million-ton nuclear bomb (80 times that of Hiroshima Atomic Bomb)
But this is much smaller than most modern nuclear bombs. It can cause blindness to people 21 kilometers away on a clear day.
It can even reach 85 kilometers on a clear night.
Heat radiation burns can cause burns on the first level within 11 km.
Secondary burns are caused within 10 km. The third-grade burns that can damage the skin tissue of the body surface are within 8 km.
[24%] Grade 3 burns can be fatal without medical emergency. The extent of it will depend on the weather of the day and the clothes you wear.
For example, white clothes can reflect most energy, and black clothes absorb it.
At the center of the Hiroshima explosion, the temperature will reach [300,000] °C.
This is equivalent to 300 times the temperature of the incineration of the body.
Such intense heat will restore the person into a basic element, and the radiation explosion will behave like the sun.
So [object] will leave a projection where the radiation does not directly hit.
But most of the energy released by the nuclear explosion is the explosion of the air that dispels the scene.
This causes the air pressure to change rapidly.
That will smash or knock down the object. [And if] we take [a] millions of tons of bombs as an example, objects within a radius of six kilometers
Will receive the equivalent of 180 tons of power
A wind speed of 255 km per hour hits a two-story building
The maximum pressure reached within 1 km radius is four times the wind speed
It also has an instant speed of 756 kilometers, although the human body can withstand such pressure.
But the wind can cause fatal collisions with nearby objects.
Therefore, the cause of death mainly comes from the collapse of the building. And the largest tonnage nuclear bomb that has been detonated in the past compared to millions of tons.
The 50 million-ton Tsar nuclear bomb is on an island in Russia.
What you see at this point is the sum of 3333 Hiroshima atomic bombs. If you happen to survive here, now you have to worry about radiation
But not all radiation is harmful, we are exposed to different forms of radiation every day, such as our mobile phones.
But the ionizing radiation at the center of the nuclear bomb has enough energy to pull electrons out of the atom.
But the amount of radiation you encounter is very much affected by your people outdoors or
It is in the interior of a wooden structure or a cement structure, and so on,
Exposure to 600 rem of radiation will have a [percent] [90] chance of causing a fatal disease,
It is estimated that 450 rem is half the estimated fatal death. But those who healed will still suffer long-term damage.
DNA molecular bonds and molecular chains are destroyed, although most can be repaired,
It will not lead to an increase in the probability of future genetic mutations and cancer.
Followed by [Fallout].
When a bomb explodes on the surface or near the ground, the explosion creates a crater and vaporizes the sediment there and brings it into the air.
It forms a mushroom cloud that you and I are familiar with, and these particles will be radioactive.
And return to the surface as a sediment after condensation
According to wind conditions,
Radiation dust can fly up to 100 kilometers, although it can appear in the form of black rain.
But most of the time you can't detect these radiations yourself. Fortunately
The radiation decay of the radiation dust is quite rapid, it will drop to 1% of the initial radiation within two weeks.
But you will have to stay in the shelter until it is over.
So what if a nuclear war breaks out? Recent research hypothesis
If you detonate 100 warheads of similar size to the Hiroshima atomic bomb, this would be like the war between India and Pakistan.
Relative to the United States, Russia, China and other countries,
Both have lower arms reserves, but this still causes huge losses.
After experiencing a nuclear attack, 5 million tons of "Black Rock" will immediately enter the atmosphere.
Will cause global temperatures to drop and reduce annual rainfall by 9%. [in spite of]
Although this change is small, it is enough to trigger crop failure and famine.
An independent study estimates that 2 billion people will fall into famine overnight in the war of 100 nuclear bombs
So what should you do? We made a film called "How to Survive in a Nuclear War."
Teach you how to survive even if the nuclear bomb is near you, you can click here to watch
Don't forget to subscribe to watch a fixed Thursday science video and click on the bell to make sure you receive notifications for our videos.
See you next week.